the winners and first-ever junior
champions are from you guys you won
Dancing with the Stars joke I love that
excitement how do you guys feel the
first ever winners of the show I feel
amazing and I just got to say oh we all
winners Oh what about the Mirrorball
Alan do you get one you only they get
one what happens actually for juniors
it's a mere start it's even better so
everybody on the team got a mirror I
love it now that you have those mirrors
stars where you gonna put it are we
gonna put the stars I'm gonna put it in
my bedroom and look at it every day
before I go surfing and remember you
guys oh I'm probably gonna put it right
in my room so right when everyone walks
in everyone can see it and it's like the
center of everyone's attention I'm gonna
get a nice trophy case and put it right
in the middle of the house so everyone
sees it
nice well you don't have a mirror ball
yet right no okay so you guys got Alan a
mirror star that's killer you guys made
him champions did it it was a team
effort
yeah Alan really a team effort hold it I
can't I know because of the use guy cuz
you work so hard yeah you were so
awesome with the speeches you gave all
season long why did you want to always
make a speech and inspire girls Vic is
sometimes girls are too afraid to do
things or like the they don't know if
they can do it or not but I just gotta
say you can do anything you can do
absolutely anything Jess you guys be be
brave have fun and do it cuz you love it
oh I love that message you guys I'm sure
our good friends now what have you kind
of learned from each other how have you
made each other better people um well
I've just learned to be like almost like
a better person she's like the most
expiring person I've ever met
in my life she's like always so nice and
kind and always listens to us and she's
such a good partner and I'm so happy
that I got her and so happy that were
such good friends now because she's so
awesome that's my look Allen I mean were
the adults here but what did you learn
from these kids I've learned so much
from them they really really like
reignited a love for dance in me you
know
it was so fun to see you guys dance
every week and to share that moment of
you guys winning literally made me cry
like he was just so I'm so grateful for
you guys tell me about that moment you
guys when they said that you were the
winners what was going through your mind
sky you first what was going through
your mind
oh I was I was just very happy but also
kind of sad because I have to say
goodbye to these people anis feel like
the hardest it was saying goodbye to
everyone and I'm gonna miss you guys so
much I love you guys and you'll always
be in a special place in my heart
you